[Musica]
ma sera tutti e devo dire che adesso è
un po più difficile fare un uno spicchio
interessante dopo quello che avete
appena visto che era veramente veramente
fantastico io ci proverò
e proverò anche ha cercato di
convincermi a quanto si possa cambiare
facilmente perché nel seguito del mio
talk
vi racconterò un po di storia della
difficoltà a volte che abbiamo di
cambiare e di come invece sia abbastanza
facile e come soprattutto il cambiamento
ris e da nella mente allora crisi crisi
purtroppo è una parola che abbiamo
sentito spesso negli ultimi anni è una
parola che riporta e ricorda momenti
difficili duri faticosi ed è una parola
sicuramente poco simpatica però per
renderlo un po più simpatica ci viene in
soccorso la sua etimologia sì perché
crisis deriva dall'antico greco crisis e
cioè scegliere scelta decidere ed
effettivamente come è possibile
collegare la crisi al cambiamento perché
effettivamente la crisi è l'anticamera
del cambiamento perché nel momento in
cui si vive un momento difficile proprio
per uscirne bisogna fare qualcosa per
cambiare
e a proposito di crisi e di cambiamento
vi voglio presentare un signore sapete
chi è questo
questo signore è roger bannister roger
bannister è un neurologo ma non è
diventato famoso per i suoi studi
roger banister è diventato famoso perché
era un mezzofondista inglese vi racconto
un po la sua storia e di come è
collegata a questo cambiamento
roger bunny sta nel 1952 alle olimpiadi
di helsinki arriva a partecipare
la finale dei 1500 metri dal grande
favorito gareggia però arriva quarto
fuori dal podio
per la grande delusione appunto entra in
crisi e la sua scelta la sua decisione
non fu quella di abbandonare come in un
primo momento aveva pensato ma di andare
avanti perché aveva un grandissimo
obiettivo
l'obiettivo di dimostrare che la scienza
aveva torto perché cosa aveva detto la
scienza la comunità scientifica fino al
1954 aveva decretato che un essere umano
non poteva correre un miglio cioè 1609
metri in meno di quattro minuti aveva
detto proprio scientificamente provato
che probabilmente il cuore sarebbe
scoppiato e che i muscoli non riuscivano
a sopportare una fatica del genere
roger banister anzi roger banister e
adesso capirete perché voleva dimostrare
il contrario vuole a cambiare questa
regola questo dogma e il 6 maggio del
1954 nella pista di atletica di oxford
corse il miglio in tre minuti 59 secondi
e 4 decimi dimostrando che la scienza
aveva torto
questa era una cosa straordinaria ma la
voglio collegare al collegamento perché
la cosa strana ancor più straordinaria
fu un'altra 47 giorni dopo
fino a quel momento non aveva fatto
nessuno 47 giorni dopo john landis
atleta australiano corse a melbourne in
3 57 e 9 prima della fine di quell'anno
da maggio a dicembre altri 37 corridori
corsero sotto i 4 minuti
l'anno successivo oltre 300 atleti con
sono sotto i 4 minuti e cosa era
successo
aveva cambiato la mente delle persone su
roger banister aveva dimostrato che era
possibile fare qualcosa che fino a quel
momento era ritenuto impossibile aveva
cambiato la mentalità aveva cambiato in
un certo senso anche la storia
già cambiare cambiare appunto lo diceva
in precedenza non è sempre facile non è
sempre facile anzi nonostante il mondo
sia in continua evoluzione noi stessi
continuiamo a cambiare
la gente però tendenzialmente ha paura
del cambiamento e perché ha paura del
cambiamento la gente seppur sia
ineluttabile fondamentalmente per due
fattori il primo è la paura dell'ignoto
perché perché un essere umano per sua
natura tenta di rifuggire l'incertezza e
quindi cerchiamo di evitare tutte quelle
situazioni che non conosciamo e
preferiamo restare nelle nostre
abitudini bella belli al caldo l'altra
potenziale paura è quella di sbagliare
sì perché siamo esseri umani però a
volte non ci permettiamo di sbagliare e
quindi pur di non farlo
preferiamo non tentare qualcosa e allora
come possiamo in qualche modo
esorcizzare queste paure per far sì che
il cambiamento sia più facile
guardando al nostro passato
sì perché se voi pensate noi pensiamo a
quando eravamo bambini a dove siamo
arrivati oggi quanti cambiamenti abbiamo
fatto con grande facilità pensate a
quando gattonava mo ci alzavamo in piedi
due passi bar avon per terra però non è
che ci fermavamo lì si rialzava in piedi
tutti ci guardavano magari anche ridendo
però noi continuavamo badaboom per terra
e ci ri alzavamo ancora fino a quando
non riuscivamo ad ottenere il nostro
obiettivo e così siamo riusciti a
camminare a scrivere a leggere ad andare
in bicicletta e tutti i cambiamenti che
abbiamo fatto fino ad oggi
certo voi direte che più si va avanti
nel tempo e più effettivamente difficile
cambiare
ed è altrettanto vero che alcuni di voi
potranno pensare che cambiare non
equivale a migliorare però è altrettanto
vero che per migliorare occorre cambiare
e allora cosa
possiamo fare per far sì che questo
avvenga più facilmente
dobbiamo toglierci queste paure come
abbiamo detto anche perché attenzione
altrimenti a un certo punto la vita
potrebbe decidere per voi
e allora non diventa più una scelta
quella di cambiare ma diventa un obbligo
e in che modo possiamo evitare questo
raccontandovi la storia di questo
signore lo conoscete
sì lo so so che effettivamente
guardandomi adesso riesce difficile
credere che sia stato giovane ma vi
giuro sono stato giovane anch'io vi
parlo un po dei miei cambiamenti questo
qui è stato il primo io sono nato e
cresciuto come vedete a milano poi un
giorno mi arriva una telefonata era un
venerdì pronto a riccardo sì ciao enzo
ciao come stai molto bene grazie
e tu bene grazie devo darti una notizia
ma dimmi enzo che abbiamo venduto a
treviso ma il rumore delle spalle che
cadevano sì perché io ad un milanese
nato e cresciuto a milano con la
famiglia a milano tutti i miei affetti
mi ha interesse a milano
ero il capitano di quella squadra in cui
ero cresciuto e per me sentirmi dire
devi andare via dalla tua realtà era
qualcosa di terrificante qualcosa che
non accettavo e infatti questo
cambiamento l'ho rifiutato seppur
dovessi andare per forza a treviso bene
sono 25 anni che vivo a treviso mi sento
molto più trevigiano che milanese e
venire a treviso è stata la mia più
grande fortuna personale professionale
però io rifiutavo questo cambiamento e
adesso mi rendo conto che invece è stata
la pia la più grossa fortuna la mia vita
ma forse il cambiamento più bizzarro e
questo sì non è o non è photoshop come
vedete c'è una differenza nonostante
usarsi la stessa maglia al di là della
stupidità di avere una bandana perché
voi capelli lunghi ma utilizzava la mano
destra è un certo punto è successo
questo la vita non mi ha fatto scegliere
sì perché a un certo punto la mia mano
destra ha smesso di funzionare
io ero totalmente destro io facevo
qualsiasi cosa con la mano destra la
sinistra potevano anche llegar mela
dietro tanto non mi serviva benissimo
allora il destino con la voluto che in
un movimento nel movimento di tiro
movimento fondamentale per la
pallacanestro le dita si chiudessero ad
artiglio in quel momento chiaramente non
potevo tenere la palla in mano e
diventavo assolutamente ridicolo da una
parte e poco competitivo allora a quel
punto anch'io ho attraversato la mia
crisi come banister come tutti noi e mi
sono posto davanti a una strada con un
bivio con due possibili decisioni
la prima smettere di giocare a risposta
sbagliata la seconda a trovare una
soluzione benissimo quella soluzione è
l'unica che ritenevo assolutamente
impossibile cioè diventare mancino e
come per far capire a chi non ha mai
giocato a pallacanestro
e come se chiedessi a tutti voi di
scrivere con l'altra mano con quella con
cui siete abituati a scrivere ma
attenzione non cominciando dalle
elementari cioè con limite stanghette no
perché io da lì a un mese cominciato il
campionato e quindi avevo poco tempo per
allenarmi per prepararli benissimo
cerco di stringere e vi dico che dopo
una settimana faceva i primi canestri in
allenamento con la mano sinistra
dopo un mese cominciava il campionato è
iniziato a tirare e assegnare con la
mano sinistra in campionato dopo tre
mesi ho fatto il mio primo canestro da
tre punti cioè da sei mete 25 con la
mano sinistra
bene e voi direte cavolo bravo io non vi
racconto questo per dirvi quanto su
quanto sia stato bravo ma quanto sia
stato scemo sì perché ho aspettato che
la vita decidesse per me se io avessi
scelto di diventare mancino
la mia carriera sarebbe stata migliore
di quello che ho avuto non che mi
lamenti ma sicuramente avrei avuto un
grande vantaggio dal poter usare
entrambe le mani e invece ho aspettato
questa necessità per avere un qualcosa
che potevo tenere perché
fondamentalmente ero sempre io
e allora arrivando alla conclusione del
mio intervento vorrei porre alcune
domande a tutti noi
la prima è perché aspettare come ho
fatto io soprattutto in un momento in
cui storico il cambiamento sta andando a
una velocità folle
la domanda che ci dobbiamo fare è non se
la mia vita cambierà la domanda migliore
che possiamo farci è come cambierà e
allora perché anziché aspettare essere
costretti di cambiare non andiamo
incontro a questo cambiamento non
andiamo verso un potenziale
miglioramento
concludo dicendo che la maggior parte
delle persone ha effettivamente paura di
cambiare
e sapete invece qual è la mia più grande
paura è quella di rimanere sempre uguale
grazie signori
[Applauso]
[Musica]